Tomb Raider the movie now with 50% more
daddy issues so there's a new trailer
for Tomb Raider and I slagged off the
last one why break with tradition cuz I
don't like this look there's one
overriding primary reason I hinted at it
with my opening joke which is that I
don't like how obsessed with her father
they're making her and there's a number
of reasons for that the the first is is
it robs her of a sense of her own agency
and say what you will about Lara Croft
over the years one thing that at the
very least original version Lara Croft
had was that she did things because she
wanted to has the character had daddy
issues yeah to varying degrees but they
were rarely the sole motivator for why
she did things maybe it was also at play
I mean heck that was even at the fringe
of the Angelina Jolie movies especially
the first one but it still wasn't the
reason she was doing things she was
hunting these artifacts because she
wanted to do that now
they managed to tie her father into that
but like the goal of finding out what
happened to her father was not was not
her starting point that was not why she
started doing this thing and more to the
point as it went along it was very clear
she enjoyed what she was doing she got
thrills enjoyment excitement out of it
and this feels like it is having her
with this obsession with her father
leading to everything that's going on
and and and then adding to that this
whole like him leaving her omission
thing which Rob serve even more agency
because now she's not even deciding what
it is she needs to do she's doing it
because the ghost of daddy told her to
and that's just frustrating for me
because Laura works best when she has a
sense of her own drive to do things
look people may get on you like look
full disclosure I am a very casual fan
of the Lara Croft video games I played a
little of the old ones I played a little
the new ones that fine for what they are
I do I do want to actually spend some
more time playing some of the newer ones
but I'm not a massive Tomb Raider fan
I do enjoy the angelina jolie movies
they're not good movies but i have fun
with them because she is fun and she's
having fun and that to me was a big part
of the appeal of the character
especially in her original incarnation
now they seem to be leaning much more
towards the version of lara croft from
the reboot series which in terms of you
know realism and not being as you know
avert least sort of sexualizing her in
terms of her physical presentation
that's fine I'm on board with that
having a little having her be a little
bit more of a survivalist cool I'm fine
with that but it it's called tomb raider
and what little I played of those newer
games raiding tombs seems to be optional
if it's there at all and I feel like
when you've got something called tomb
raider and raiding tombs is incidental
to the plot then somebody has missed the
mark and then and again that's not
saying that they haven't done good
things elsewhere with some of the
changes they made to the characters but
I I feel like we've lost the thread of
what was fun about these games in the
first place and maybe it's again maybe
it's cuz I haven't spent enough time
with the newer stuff but it still is
frustrating for me just just watching
this because like can't she decide to do
something on her own does it have to be
this Drive of living up to her father
because so far in this second trailer
especially it was a little bit in the
first one but this second one especially
everything is tying back to that I'm
just saying they're going is she gonna
have a single decision she makes for it
makes for herself that is not just an
in-the-moment actioning choice because
it doesn't look
like she's going to now that having been
said fair's fair
the action looks really good I mean it
looks hard-hitting it looks intense when
she's like running through and she's got
the bow and arrow loved it
that's awesome but I've said before a
limited doses of great spectacle won't
save something that I'm otherwise not
enjoying and that's not and that's not
me going like a I need a deep story I
can't turn my brain I can turn my brain
off that the John wick movies are not
particularly deep but I still have fun
with them because you know this the
story that's being told is a dumbed-down
story but it's one that I oh okay
nifty and it gets me from action piece
to action piece but when a story tries
to pretend like it's about something and
it's this deeper dive but it's like no
you're just not even if the action is
good like I'm I'm not enjoying being
here I have to I have to enjoy the
character if I'm gonna watch the
character just just mantle you know all
these enemies as cool as that may be in
isolation if I don't inherently care
about either the situation of the
character or ideally both then it it's
just it's just existing in a vacuum and
I'll just go okay cool and move on and
that's kind of what I'm afraid is gonna
happen with this Tomb Raider movie now
I'm also on record as having said
repeatedly but I don't think video game
movies are going to work possibly ever
video game based TV shows maybe but
movies I just I think we need to stop
and nothing that I've seen so far about
the new tumor in your movie aside from
what looks like some admittedly
excellently executed action stuff looks
like it's gonna turn that trend around
it just it doesn't and that's a shame
because even though I again casual fan I
do like this character I do and I've I
love I love treasure hunt movies I love
Indiana Jones
I love Nathan Drake and uncharted I even
loved the national treasure movies of a
Nicholas Cage they're not good but I
still enjoy the mama
The Goonies I'm a sucker I'm a total
sucker for a treasure hunt especially if
you can add in like those weird
elaborate puzzles in ancient tongue I
love all that so the fact that I'm
watching a Tomb Raider trailer and going
I'm not seeing a heck of a lot of what I
the natural appeal that just the title
has for me to say nothing about the
appeal that the character normally has
for me that just leaves me kind of on
the whole thing but those are my
thoughts on the latest trailer for Tomb
Raider have you seen it did you like it
better than me what did you see that I
missed whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it
do all the things like subscribe Twitter
I got a podcast I got a patreon if
you're the generous type links for all
that stuff's down below and until next
time
it's councils adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]